du théâtre cette fois sur les planches
avec le roi lear à paris nouvelle
adaptation très libre avec michel
piccoli 81 ans le roi est devenu un
parrain mafieux dans les années 30
sophie jouve philippe g cela il vient de
jouer pendant 2h40 le roi lear un rôle
écrasant et ça ne se voit pas c'est une
quelle jouissance ce métier que quand en
plus quand il ya du monde que les gens
écoutent tellement bien ça va on devait
alléger ce fut dur ce roi lear là se
passe dans les années 30 époques de
toutes les compromissions et de toutes
les dictatures pour entourer cet homme
bafouée par ses filles une troupe qui se
hisse à la hauteur du mythe piccoli ça
manque de générosité de gentillesse de
de méchanceté de tous il peut il peut
tout faire il est tout est petit jouet
c'est pour ça qu'il peut tout jouer
oui oui avoir comme time she came rêve
le plus fou et il fallait à picot dit le
sentiment de l'âge pour accepter de
jouer un tel personnage
il aura hésité 70
si on ne réussit pas dans sa vie par
moment avoir des accès de folie dans
tous les domaines c'est très très
dommage je je trouve je trouve cette
deux ans via des images saisissantes un
rôle nourris de toute une vie une troupe
où chacun joue pour les autres voilà
comment trois heures de théâtre vous
reste dans la mémoire